there is a sense of frustration of anger
of moments of error becoming fatal or
near fatal mistakes sixteen-year-old
Ralph yarl knocked on the wrong door in
Missouri looking for his brothers he was
shot twice once in the head the 84 year
old man who fired the shorts not
initially charged but now facing Court
after local protests as the prosecutor
Clay County I can tell you there was a
racial component to the case President
Joe Biden has pushed for new gun control
legislation he called garel telling him
he hopes for a quick recovery vice
president Kamala Harris tweeting out
let's be clear no child should ever live
in fear of being short for ringing the
wrong doorbell
as people were trying to absorb how such
a thing Could Happen halfway across the
country a 20 year old woman shot dead
the car she was in turned around in a
driveway in New York state with a
companion killing Gillis was looking for
a friend's house she was shot in the
back the homeowner now facing murder
charges while they were leaving the
residence once they determined that
they're at the wrong house
a subject
came out on his porch for whatever
reason
and fired two shots
one of which struck the vehicle that
Kailyn was in
the New Mexico body cam footage has now
been released of a man shot and killed
by police officers Robert Dodson had no
idea who would be at his door in the
middle of the night so took his gun a
fatal decision
the police were at the wrong house
one gun control group says the Spate of
incidents can be traced to one real
issue we have got a epidemic here a
public health epidemic that has risen to
a level in which an entire generation of
people are going to come up on what's
being known as the lockdown generation
we can't be feel safe from gun violence
in any part of our communities these
most recent cases are bringing a lot of
national attention as well as anguish
and sympathy but for the moment
no real change
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Washington